it's the first positive move in five
years between Ukraine and Russia a
filmmaker and a group of sailors landed
in Kiev Airport in a long anticipated
prisoner swap the release of Ukrainian
filmmaker oleg sentsov who was jailed
for 22 years is seen as a major
concession by russia and president
Vladimir's olenski fulfilled his
election promise to bring home 22
ukrainian sailors and two security
service agents we have to do all the
steps to finish this horrible war I
think the sailors on board three
Ukrainian vessels were captured here in
the Kerch Strait nine months ago after
Russian warships opened fire on them
the Kremlin says they illegally entered
Russian waters near the Crimean
Peninsula which Russian troops seized
and annexed from Ukraine in 2014
since then the Kremlin backed
separatists have been at war with
Ukrainian government forces in eastern
Ukraine at least 10,000 people have been
killed since the fighting began five
years ago Ukraine's recently elected
president zalenski says he wants to
revive peace negotiations with Russia
he's been seeking support from European
leaders recently and he spoken to
President Vladimir Putin by phone the
prisoner exchange could be an important
step towards further tentative talks the
swap is being seen as a victory for both
presidents Putin and zalenski a
potential suspect and witness in the
downing of the Malaysian Airlines jet
over Ukraine five years ago has also
been released despite protests by the
Dutch government who had many of its
citizens on the flight that suggests the
Lenski not only had to make concessions
but that Russia will be a tough
negotiating partner in future talks to
end fighting in eastern Ukraine Victoria
Gaytan be al-jazeera